is news of two planned cinematic Star
Trek movies a lie welcome to Sid truck
your SciFi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel welcome to North Wales where it
is beautiful but
freezing that's the Hat where I want to
talk to you about the great Star Trek I
don't saying it's a lie is a bit of an
exaggeration let's say the great Star
Trek Bluff let's say that instead that's
more accurate to be honest so what am I
talking about I'm talking about this
news that was dropped last week on
Deadline that announced that Not only
was Star Trek 4 with Chris Pine Etc
still in development but actually there
was a second movie as well the there was
a writer and a director and everything
announced the guy from Andor was going
to be directed and that actually um this
was in development and it suggested that
this was green lit and this was leaked
from sources at Paramount I said at the
time I suspected this uh leak had
actually come from Bad Robot not
Paramount and I can now confirm that I
was right this leak has come from Bad
Robot not Paramount so someone a Bad
Robot has decided to leak the story to
deadline that yes the two movies are in
development and it is
true there is a development process in
place and there is a script for this
prequel movie that is supposed to be um
a oh God I don't even know I don't even
know how to describe it but it's
supposed to be an origin story which
makes me just dread that we're going to
be seeing Captain Kirk at school but I
we don't know any details yet so it's
hard to say but there is this origin
movie and Star Trek 4 is still in what
they call call Active development the
problem
is they then don't tell you the next bit
Paramount has not green lit either of
these projects Paramount has not put any
pen to paper for either of these
projects Bad Robot is developing these
movies as pitch plans they will be
pitching these to Paramount they will be
saying look this is what we've got this
is what we're doing this is what we'd
like to do and Paramount will then green
light or and has agreed to spend the
money Paramount apparently according to
my sources I livid that this was um
leaked the way it has been and they are
directly blaming Bad Robot Bad Robot is
saying it wasn't me goof hand on hard
you know Scout honor we didn't do it but
everybody about this screams that it was
bad robot that did it whether this was
one or two people that pad robot that
decided to jump the gun or whether this
was a concerted plan is the conversation
now why would it be a conservative plan
well I I discussed this in the last
video a little bit so I'm going to be
rehashing but what I basically said and
I've been confirmed to be accurate is
that bad robots deal with Warner
Brothers their exclusivity deal does
come to an end uh this year in August
and they are looking for a new um
project they they want that next big
franchise and they're hoping that that
will be Star Trek now I have got a
little bit of a treat for you before I
carry on this story for one look at that
and
now look at that this is where I get to
weekend how good say
so they're looking for that next big
project they're looking for those two
big movies that they can get into
production and they can start making
some money the only really big franchise
that they're currently involved in or
have any involvement in is Star Trek now
Paramount has not as I said in the last
video have not closed the door on Star
Trek 4 yet it's not cancelled but it is
on the back burner it is not a priority
right now for Paramount they have much
bigger fish to fry they have much bigger
projects on the go for example they've
just announced that there will be a Top
Gun three now that for Paramount is a
big deal sadly Star Trek right now isn't
I'm going to get a out of the wind a
little bit for you even though wow
hello So Bad Robot may have actually
leaked this information on purpose to
try and leverage Paramount a little bit
The Hope being that there would be a big
positive um public us trekkies basically
would react very positively to this and
that would then give Bad Robot more
emphasis to then when they go into to
these pitch meetings and they go to try
and get these things agreed say look
look people really really want these
movies let's do it yeah the sad thing is
the reaction wasn't massively popular
towards the idea of this prequel um
origin story but I do think a lot of
people do actually want to see the Chris
Pine Star Trek movie so I hope
personally that will happen I like the
first three no I like the first H I like
the first
one uh I like most of the first one I
think they cast it well uh I do like
them honest but and they're not Star
Trek films they're not they're really
good action Sci-Fi movies that's what
they are um I wouldn't mind another good
action sci-fi movie with a cast I really
like so I'd quite like that the prequel
movie it really depends on what the hell
it is because I think that could be
really interesting and it could be
bloody awful and with the bulk of of
evidence that we've had with Star Trek
over the last 10 years I think is going
to be bloody awful but we on this
channel try not to judge things before
we actually see them
so but that's my opinion that's my
concern I should say Paramount why a
Paramount so angry and why wouldn't they
have wanted this to be leaked they have
a very big year ahead of them the entire
future of the company currently is at
stake because Redstone who own the
controlling share of of um Paramount
shares is selling up and apparently they
are going to sell to the highest bidder
So currently anybody could step in and
buy Paramount and Paramount Global
itself as a business has no control over
that they cannot control who Redstone
decide to sell those shares to so all of
a sudden one of Hollywood's biggest
Studios and don't forget this is CBS as
well is up for sale now the initial
Insider opinion was that CBS would be
separated off and it would be Paramount
sold one way and CBS the other but
actually what's happened is because of
redstone that might not happen after all
it may just be Paramount Global as a
whole now the people that are currently
looking to buy into Paramount Global
would be Warner Brothers which would be
a merger and basically a transfer of
debt rather than actually buying shares
there's also interest from sky dance
which is basically funded by the Saudi
government so uh I'm not sure that's
going to go past the FTC with making one
of Hollywood's biggest media companies
owned by the state I don't think that's
going to go down well but we'll see what
happens there or I am hearing rumors
that actually Apple would be very
interested in this as well particularly
as it's a cash buy and it would be far
simpler than the MGM deal so Apple might
be interested in
this
Paramount do not want any risks right
now and Star Trek to the cinema is a
risk Star Trek onment plus not a risk
that will do well it will do absolutely
fine Cinema not so much so bad robot
trying to get themselves a job is not
going down well with certain people that
power out right now and I actually think
that this Bluff is going to backfire so
what do I mean by that I don't think
we're going to get these straight to
cinnamon movies and I don't think Bad
Robot is going to get What It Wants I
think these films have pretty much been
cancelled and I actually think this
Bluff by Bad Robot is going to massively
backfire on them but we're going to have
to wait and see because only time will
tell but guys I want you to get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think is this a Bluff My Bad Robot and
if it is do you think it's a clever one
or a really really stupid one I'd love
to know exactly what you think to get
into the comments also what do you think
of the view how nice is that it's s rain
and um finally what do you think of Star
Trek future as a whole where do you
think Star Trek's going in the next 5 to
10 years I'd love to know what you think
get into the comments as always if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to
patreon.com trck where most of our new
videos do appear first and you get to
see them without the advert you lucky
bunnies finally go to s.co do.uk where
we do articles based on most of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more information for you to digest so go
check that out too please stay safe
enjoy nature in the outdoors cuz it's
awesome and uh stay warm it's really
cold I'll see you
[Music]
soon